Ciao ragazzi benvenuti alla seconda
puntata di "Pesce d'Aprile"
Allora la scorsa puntata è stata pregna
di emozioni, abbiamo riso, cioè hanno riso
io basito, hashtag basito tutto il tempo.
Speriamo che adesso che riprenderemo ad
ascoltare i messaggi le cose migliorino.
Mi impegnerò. No ragazzi no schi...non possiamo
iniziare così! Enrico ma che stai...Questo video non si può pubblicare (Enrico)
No Enrico. Di nuovo stai morendo? Cioè voi vi
rendete conto che qui parliamo di diversity, sensibilizziamo le persone
a volersi più bene.
Ma come si può volere bene a una persona
come voi? Io vi chiedo scusa perché
solitamente sono dei
contenuti più alti, ma più alti basta
anche tipo non lo so il tema del citofono
sarebbe stato più alto rispetto...che te ridi? Smettila io non voglio più sentirti ridere
Il tema del citofono, tu sei un esperto di citofoni (Enrico)
Eccoti qui. Voglio raccontarvi lo scherzo che
feci per il pesce d'aprile ad una mia amica
Dovevamo andare a Roma con la macchina, io
dietro la macchina le ho attaccato
questo biglietto con scritto "Suonare se
volete un p****o"
Non ti dico per tutta la strada quante
persone le suonavano e lei non capiva perché
E' stato bellissimo. E dopo quel viaggio
la sua amica non aveva più i denti
Io prima sentivo dal bagno che ridevate per un pesce
d'aprile di Roshane. No vabbè una cosa
tranquilla quella in realtà. Cioè? Stavo co
questa ragazza, la sera prima era andato a
una cena di classe in cui ci stava questa
ragazza con cui ero già stato insieme, lei
sapeva che lei ci stava e non voleva che io
c'andassi. Io ci andai lo stesso e siccome
il giorno dopo la domenica delle palme
cascava sul primo aprile ho detto "Mo le
faccio uno scherzo". So andato la, tutto il
tempo l'ho evitata, quando l'ho incontra le
faccio "Guarda more ti devo parlare" , no "Francesca ti devo parlare", non le ho detto neanche amore
Ci siamo messi appoggiati alla ringhiera,
guardavamo avanti
io gli dico "Eh guarda ieri sai ci stava Serena, ho
bevuto un po' e lei a un certo punto mi ha dato un bacio
l'ho scansata". Attimo di pausa no? Per fare
un po'...ho aspettato tipo 30 secondi in silenzio
lei mi fa "E?",  io faccio "Io non più ho nessuna
certezza"
C'era rimasta malissimo per sta cosa no?
Non sapevo che fare
lei non risponde, mi giro con le guance
rigate di lacrime no? E io "hahah" scoppiato a
ridere...Lei si è girata mi ha tirato un pizzone in faccia
Ancora me lo ricordo mi ha fatto un male, che
lei faceva pure karate, quindi nel senso...e ha fatto
bene. In realtà non era vero niente?!
No era vero. No nono
Poi la cosa che fa ridere, vabbè questa non la mettere...non la metto...
...Pesce d'aprile!"...Non si può mettere, ragazzi stiamo
veramente tornando alle medie
cioè, questo video è perfetto per tutte le
persone che hanno dai 12 anni in giù
Io odio gli scherzi. Io li adoro invece. Ma
anche se te li fanno? Si si, poi mi vendico
peggio, però rido, rido tanto da morire. E'
divertente capito? Vedere la persona sofferente
No regà. Tu hai fatto uno scherzo assurdo...
della mano
(Enrico )Ahhh terribile. Ero a casa al mare di un amico che mi aveva invitato. Dormivano in camere separate
e...vedevo che a una certa
ora non dormiva, c'era la luce accesa
Quindi che faccio, mi avvicino per vedere
cosa stesse facendo e lo vedevo con
l'ipod. Per fortuna perché vorrei beccare molto
peggio.  (Enrico) Esatto! Se non che decido allora di sgattaiolare sotto il suo letto, che era
vicino alla porta finestra aperta, quindi
decido di sbattere la porta finestra per
vedere una una sua reazione no? Ma niente.
Allora ai piedi del suo letto c'era un
altro letto con le rotelle,
quindi ho la giusta idea di andare ai piedi
del letto e scuotere violentemente il letto...
con le rotelle...con le rotelle e si vede
lui che inizia ad alzarsi sul letto "Oddio mamma aiuto aiuto!"
Io già ero scappato...(Enrico) Si stava c*****o adosso, il tempo che è sceso dal letto gli ho
afferrato la caviglia e...è morto! Perché è
caduto sul comodino, per quello è morto proprio
Ciao e ciao ospite, allora...
Ciao Gu e ciao ospite...
*tosse Enrico*. Enrico! Ma fumi? Ma allora che problemi.. *risata Enrico*
Non fa ridere. Stiamo abbassando il livello di Vita Buttata in un modo (Gianmarco)... Ma Virus Buttata.
Ciao Gu e ciao ospite, allora lo scherzo di cui vi andrò a parlare l'ha fatto mia mamma a me, a mio
fratello e a mia nonna. Mia mamma va al
bagno, non avendo niente di meglio da
fare decine di truccarsi facendosi un occhio nero
Ovviamente essendo sola in bagno noi non la
vediamo, lei prende un flacone di shampoo
quando ha finito, lo lancia per terra urlando (*cane che abbaia*)
e si butta per terra appoggiata a piangere per finta
per finta. Noi ovviamente sentendo questo
trambusto andiamo in bagno e la troviamo buttata
per terra dicendo "No ho sbattuto, ho sbattuto".
Si toglie la mano, questo occhio nero. Io
comincio a piangere perché comunque ero
piccolina, avevo una decina d'anni, mio
fratello 4 meno di me, mia nonna
spaventatissima.  Poi comincia a ridere. Ma tua madre
è orribile. Bambini di 11 e 7 anni quindi proprio...capito
con un occhio fuori. Ma poi che rumore faceva il
flacone quando cadeva per terra che ha
abbaiato. C'è stato un rumore strano c'è stato
Perché un cane. Io pensavo fosse il flacone...Il flacane (Enrico). *risate*
Il flacane?...Siamo al livello di una flacane?
Sta diventando pessimo (Gianmarco). Gianmarco che sta succedendo?
Ma tu sei connesso con me mentalmente? Loro due sono connessi
fra di loro. No io sono in mezzo devo dire (Gianmarco)
Un po' cedi al fascino, ok. Flacane...Il flacane?...Mi sto a strozzà io
*risata folle di Enrico"
Ragazzi io sono, io sono mortificato io
vi chiedo perdono. Tutto apposto? Stavi partorendo
Nono, tutto apposto. Possiamo riprendere?
Ciao Gu e ciao ospite, è la terza volta che provo a fare questo messaggio quindi
spero che sia quella buona. Per quanto
riguarda gli scherzi epici io e altre
mie due coinquiline abbiamo deciso di...
*risata folle di Enrico*
Sto sudando. Può esse che l'ultima puntata che è stata fatta di sera
può esse che quella con Claudio? (Gianmarco)
Si, forse è la
sera che non bisogna farle. Era impazzito (Gianmarco)...
sta impazzendo di nuovo
Allora vediamo se riusciamo a sentirlo
questo messaggio per la quarta volta
Ciao Gu e ciao ospite, è la terza volta che
provo a fare questo messaggio quindi
spero che sia quella buona. Per quanto
riguarda gli scherzi epici io e altre mie
due coinquiline abbiamo deciso di ricoprire
la stanza di un'altra nostra coinquilina
con la carta d'alluminio. Ricoprivamo
ogni cosa ci capitasse sottomano, quindi
il cuscino, deodorante, smalti, carta d'identità
volevamo fare le cose bene, abbiamo
deciso di ricoprire l'entrata della sua
porta con la carta trasparente.
Peccato che ci abbia sgamato e adesso ne
sto ancora subendo le conseguenze...Non so cosa dirti
Io mi ricordo la carta igienica ovunque per la stanza (Enrico)
Bellissimo! Abbiamo riempito completamente
tutta la stanza di carta igienica
ma poi fatta bene, non buttata
qua la, proprio abbiamo fatto il filo bene che
andava dappertutto. Ragazzi ma due
anni una cosa così
E poi aspè, qual'era quell'altra barbarie che facevate, quella...
Ma roba che a un certo punto non riusciamo a
dormire per la puzza, quindi abbiamo dovuto mettere
gli asciugamani sotto...c'avevo le foto ma le ho dovute
eliminare
No che schifo, che schifo ragazzi! che schifo!
*risata folle di Enrico". Che schifo, che schifo...che schifo
Io sono mortificato ma queste qui, cioè io non
è che posso cacciarle via queste persone
sono, cioè è la mia famiglia.
Sono imbarazzato. Ciao Gu ciao, c'era
madre che mi veniva a svegliare tutti
i giorni per andare a scuola e un giorno
il primo d'aprile, ho deciso di farle questo scherzo, lei mi viene
a svegliare, io non m'alzo dal letto, mi
chiama, mi chiama, mi chiama ma niente accende la
luce niente non mi sveglio, alza la
serranda non mi sveglio. A un certo punto mi agita nel
letto, io continuo a far finta di non
svegliarmi. Vabbè lei tutta tranquilla mi apre
gli occhi con con le dita, ho rivoltato
gli occhi quindi le è preso un infarto. Lei si era
quasi messa a piangere, gridando per
casa "E' morto è morto!", è arrivato mi padre pure
tutti agitati. Alla fine ho detto "Pesce d'Aprile". Inutile aggiungere le botte che
ho preso quel giorno...Anche giustamente. Ed è è morto, l'hanno ucciso. Mia
madre me lo rinfaccia ancora dicendomi
che è stata l'unica volta in cui...è stata felice...che lei è
è diventata bianca dalla paura
Si ma tua madre doveva ucciderti. Meno male che no sarò mai madre
Ragazzi ma veramente non avevamo più nessuna persona da invitare per Vita Buttata?
A questo punto prendo chiunque
Venite tutti quanti a casa mia. Roshane!
Però Enrico ha riso...Enrico sta ridendo
dall'inizio. Lo scherzo che t'hanno fatto a te, il sacco del letto te lo ricordi?...Te lo ricordi (Enrico)
Allora praticamente, si ma io non me ne sono mai reso conto
Ti faccio vedere come funziona. Questo è uno scherzo molto divertente
molto semplice, praticamente se questo
qui è il materasso e questo è il
lenzuolo rimboccato sopra, con sopra il
copriletto ok? Quindi tu hai il
copriletto...Allora tu hai il lenzuolo sopra il
letto ok? Prendi lenzuolo, lo infili
sotto al letto, togli il piumone e dai piedi del letto
lo tiri su, lo coprì con il piumone in
modo che chi entra dentro praticamente
non riesce a entrare perché fa un
effetto sacco. Ora non so quanto abbiate
capito. Me lo fanno a me...vado, apro il...alzo le coperte e "traaa". Non ci credo! E mi addormento. Allora arriva
*in sottofondo risata folle di Enrico*
Arriva mio fratello Gabriele, dice "Ma strano che Guglielmo non sia venuto a dirmi"...Cioè tu non ti sei
accorto di niente? Loro hanno alzato di nascosto il copriletto e hanno visto che io avevo sfondato
...avevo sfondato il lenzuolo...Era un pannolone, cioè io avevo le gambe che erano entrate nel letto,  l'avevo
sfondato, quindi il sacco non aveva
funzionato. Cioè tu non ti sei accorto di
niente in tutto questo? Io non mi sono
accorto che avevano praticamente... No non
ti sei accorto di aver rotto...Zero! Zero! Com'è possibile? Io sono entrato e "stra", e mi sono addormentato
Non ne ho idea, secondo me non l'avevano
fatto bene o era un lenzuolo usurato. Non ti tagli le
unghie dei piedi, non lo so...Esatto
*risata folle di Enrico*
E' tutto censurato, è tutto...( Enrico) Sarà muto, Charlie Chaplin ahhahahah
Che cosa? Enrico stava cercando di dire che questo video sarà così muto che sembrerà Charlie Chaplin
*risata folle di Enrico"
Stai perdendo il senno
*risata*. Flacane?...Domani me lo tatuo...Il pesce d'aprile più assurdo l'ho fatto
al mio compagno, l'ho distrutto in una
sola giornata non sapeva più se stare
con me o uccidermi. Gli ho messo il dado
Knorr nel soffione della doccia
L'ho mandato al lavoro che praticamente
puzzava di brodo, è arrivato al lavoro
ha aperto la Coca cola, gli avevo legato la
Mentos col filo interdentale
Una volta aperto il tappo la Mentos è scesa
in fondo alla bottiglia di Coca cola ed è
schizzata su tutto, su tutti i muri e una
volta uscito fuori con i nostri
colleghi di lavoro gli avevo chiuso la
macchina in mezzo ai carrelli della
spesa. Cioè lui è uscito con le mani nei capelli, non sapeva più che cosa fare. Voleva uccidermi. Detto
questo ti faccio tanti saluti,
sei il numero uno veramente degli youtuber
per me, sei fantastico ti seguo dal primo video, non
smetterò mai di seguirti. Un bacio, ciao ciao.
Grazie mille sei stata gentilissima e sono
contento di starti simpatico anche se
tutte le persone alle quali vuoi bene
finiscono male, quindi...spero di non
incontrarti mai
"Tutte le persone intorno a te stanno morendo, anche il tuo cane!". Oddio "Anche il mio cane? Si è morto!"
"L' ho investito venendo qua". Comunque lei Macgyver (Enrico). Ragazzi si cioè, lei ti rendi conto
che cosa ha fatto? Guarda che lega la Mentos è
difficilissimo, io c'ho provato tantissimo non ci so mai riuscito. Perché l'ha sempre mangiata (Enrico)
No si è sempre infilato nel c**o la Coca cola...Ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine di questa tragedia, io
non vi voglio mai più vedere, a nessuno di
voi a casa mia. Aspettatevi una
secchiata di olio bollente dal balcone. Che poi Gianmarco è peggio di noi eh per dirla
tutta. Perché? No io so contenermi meglio di Enrico sicuramente (Gianmarco). Gianmarco, secondo me
pure un cane in calore si sa contenere meglio di Enrico...Infatti (Gianmarco)
Io ti ringrazio Roshane per questo
contributo unico che hai dato a questa
rubrica. Che altro aggiungere addio...
Comunque no a parte gli scherzi grazie
mille per essere venuto qui, grazie a voi
per aver resistito fino a questo momento
siete veramente stati molto molto forti.
Fateci sapere qua sotto quali sono
stati magari che ne so, degli scherzi
simpatici che avete fatto o anche
semplicemente per insultare Roshane e Enrico
per il loro humor becero. Che dire
iscrivetevi come sempre, lasciate un mi pia...che c***o me ne frega, non lasciate un  "mi piace"
Lasciate un "mi piace" alla vostra vita, quella è la cosa più importante. Però se non volete perdere
altri video attivate anche la campellina qua sotto
Noi ci vediamo la prossima settimana con
un altro Vita Buttata. Ciao. Ciao
Oddio grazie a Dio è finita...Bravo spegnile
E' quasi poetico...spegni...(*pernacchia*). Enrico... Enrì, ma che è?...Ma che è?
Sipario